Bitte schön.
Hallo. Guten Abend. Mein Name ist Kästal Göckert.
Ich bin die zuständige Erstensprache.
Bevor wir zu Ihren Bescheiden kommen, lassen Sie mich einfach Informationen über die Notieren.
Okay, wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Alexandra Holkamp.
Alexandra Holkamp.
Kannst du Sie hier vor uns machen?
Mit Langsam und kurz gesteibieren.
Ja, Alexandra schreibt sich A L E X A N D R A.
Ja, genau.
Und Holkamp Ha O L T K A M P.
Ja, ich bin eine Frau.
Ja, okay, Alexandra Holkamp.
Ja, Frau Holkamp, wie alt sind Sie?
38.
Ja, genau sind Sie geworden.
Am 16. Dezember 1983.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1 Meter 70 groß und wiege 65 Kilo.
65. Okay.
Was sind Sie von Beruf, Frau Holkamp?
Ich bin Lehrerin.
Okay, welche Richtung oder welche Abteilung?
In einer Grundschule.
Okay, gut an die Schule.
Okay.
Was haben Sie von Beruf, Frau Holkamp?
Ich bin ein Kind.
Vorher ratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, keine Kinder.
Keine Kinder.
Okay.
Danke schön für die Informationen.
Frau Holkamp, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Weiche Besparen haben Sie immer mal?
Ja, also seit 3 Tagen geht es mir nicht gut.
In müde und abgeschlagen habe Schüttelfrost.
Das war heute Vormittag bis 39,4.
39,4, okay.
Und ich habe starkes Schwitzen.
Und auch etwas Durchfall.
Okay.
Und Durchfall.
Zuerst würde ich gerne wissen,
wo haben das Temperatur,
oder das Tiba gemessen?
Im Mund.
Okay.
Und Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie leiden unter Durchfall.
Wie viel müssten Sie auf die Toilette gehen?
Oder wie viel mal haben Sie durchfällig?
Seit gestern, seit einem Tag, 7, 8 Mal.
Okay.
Haben Sie ungewöhnliches bemerkt?
Ihren Stuhl.
Zum Beispiel, Brut?
Nein, kein Brut.
Ein Brut.
Einfach sehr flüssig.
Sehr flüssig.
Okay.
Und haben Sie ungewöhnliches Bemerk?
Haben Sie ungewöhnliches etwas gegessen?
Zum Beispiel andere Dinge gegessen?
Püner, Mayonnaise, Aja.
Nichts besonderes.
Ich habe das gegessen, was mein Mann gegessen hat.
Dem geht es gut.
Vielleicht.
Okay, kein Problem.
Okay.
Ja, seit 3 Tagen.
Sind Sie im anderen Ort?
Zum Beispiel sind Sie im Ausland?
3 Tage.
Oder in Deutschland?
Ich war vor ungefähr 5 Wochen, wenn ich 5 Wochen, ja,
4 bis 5 Wochen bin ich aus einem von einer Reise zurückgekommen.
Da war ich in Vietnam und Cambodia.
Vietnam.
Okay, Cambodia.
Okay.
Ja, okay.
Aber sind die wichtige Impfungen schon gehabt?
Oder haben die schon die Impfungen gehabt?
Für diese Reise war ich vorher bei einem Tropenmediziner.
Ich habe mir die notwendigen Impfungen gegeben.
Ich habe auch Tabletten gegen Malaria eingenommen.
Ja, okay.
Allerdings habe ich die 4 Tage nicht genommen,
weil ich so auch einen starken Magendahminfekt hatte.
Und da konnte ich die gar nicht nehmen.
Mir war es so schlecht.
Das war ungefähr 4 Tage, aber ich habe die Tabletten nicht genommen.
Das war in Cambodia.
Cambodia, ja.
Okay.
Ja, okay.
Ich verstehe.
Und ist ihr,
oder ist ihr Fieber dauerhafter?
Oder hat Welen geholfen?
Also, ich jetzt seit 3 Tagen, ich habe immer gemessen,
morgens ist es etwas niedriger,
aber im Abend war es, wie gesagt, über 39.
Aber es war jetzt die letzten 3 Tage immer Fieber.
Okay.
Und ist Ihnen übel?
Ja, also mir ist schon auch schlecht,
aber ich habe jetzt nicht mehr geholfen.
Aber ich habe keinen Appetit bei dem Fieber.
Ja, ich habe keine Appetit.
Nicht erbrochen, aber kein Appetit.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ja, okay.
Und haben Sie irgendwelche Schmerzen?
Vielleicht leiden Sie ja.
Meine Muskeln tun weh, so wie starker Muskelkater.
Und auch die Gelenke schmerzen.
Also, ich möchte mich nicht bewegen.
Das tut alles weh.
Okay, aber leiden Sie keine Krippen oder Tapfalsgefühl
oder andere Dinge?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie deswegen Fieber etwas eingenommen
oder wegen Ihrer Beschwerden etwas eingenommen
als Medikamente?
Bisher habe ich nichts eingenommen.
Ich nehme ungern Medikamente ein.
Ich nehme eigentlich keine Schmerz-Tabletten ein.
Aber jetzt fahren wir das doch zu lange und zu hoch.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt ins Krankenhaus gegangen.
Okay.
Sind Sie gegen Hepatite A oder Hepatite B
schon einmal geimpft?
Ja, das hat alles der Tropen-Mediziner geimpft.
Ja, okay.
Sie haben es schon gemacht.
Ich habe keine Erkennung bekommen.
Ich habe etwas auch hinzufügen als weitere Beschwerden.
Nein, das habe ich alles gesagt, was ich zu schweren habe.
Okay, fahr vollkommen.
Jetzt würde ich gerne über Ihre andere Vorgeschichte etwas fragen.
Leiden Sie an krönchen Erkrankungen.
Ich meine Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit
oder erhöchste Blutfetwerte,
wie sind die Seriom-Kaffer?
Ich muss auch fragen.
Ich habe eine Schilddrüsen-Vergröserung.
Da gibt es auch einen Knoten in der Schilddrüse.
Ich werde immer kontrolliert und ich musste auch ein Medikament nehmen.
Was nehmen Sie?
Da geht es hinein.
Das Medikament heißt Ultirox.
Da steht hinter 75.
Ich nehme morgens eine Tablette ein.
Okay, und was noch?
Sonst nehme ich keine Medikamente ein.
Keine Medikamente?
Bei Bedarf oder realmäßig?
Nein.
Nehmen Sie keine Medikamente ein?
Okay.
Und gibt es andere krönliche Erkrankungen?
Nein, krönisch nicht.
Ich bin als Kind operiert worden.
Ich habe eine Mandel-Operation.
Da war ich 11 Jahre alt.
Weil ich oft Eitrige Angina hatte.
Die hat dann auch zu einer Nierenentzündung geführt.
Da hatte ich häufiger Infekte.
Das war nicht so gut.
Ich hatte eine andere Erkrankung.
Zuletzt hatte ich vor fünf Jahren eine Nierenentzündung.
Und da hatte ich auch Großfiebern.
Nierenentzündung, ja.
Mit 13 Jahren bin ich am Blindarm operiert worden.
13 Jahre?
Ja, sie war 11 Jahre alt.
Mit 15 Jahren bin ich am Mandel operiert worden.
Ja mit von 13 Jahren am Blindarm.
Die haben einen Billentarm-Op.
Mit Lego
haben die
Und gibt es in Ihrem Familie kronische Erkrankungen?
Ich meine, Ihre Vater, meine Schwester, meine Kinder.
Mein Vater ist 67 Jahre alt und seit vier Jahren hat er Lobby.
Ich könnte Ihnen noch mal sagen.
Blutkrebs, ich glaube Leukämie heißt das.
Leukämie, okay.
Aber er lebt noch.
Es geht eigentlich ganz gut.
Er wird abgelbt und ist in Kontrolle.
Sehr schön.
Meine Mutter ist 66 Jahre alt.
Als sie 46 Jahre alt war, hatte sie Brustkrebs.
Das ist gerührt worden und behandelt worden und wurde kontrolliert.
Aber das ist seitdem, ist das...
Alles klar.
Auch sehr gut.
Und haben Sie eine Schwester?
Ja, eine Schwester, die ist 36 Jahre alt, die hat Asthma.
36 Jahre Asthma.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ja, okay.
Und gehen Sie zum regermäßig-brauern-Arzt oder besuchen Sie regermäßig-brauern-Arzt?
Mach ich regelmäßig.
Einmal im Jahr gehe ich auch zum Urulogen und lasse die Niere kontrollieren.
Und das war zuletzt aber so weit in Ordnung.
Aber der letzte schwere Infekt war vor fünf Jahren ungefähr.
Ja, Sie haben schon gesagt, ja, nie den Entzündung.
Po fünf Jahre.
Ja, wissen Sie, gibt es diesen Fall für Ihre nie-seben Entzündung?
Man hat damals gesagt, aufgrund, weil ich so oft Mandelentzündungen hatte.
Aha ja.
Und dann, bis die Mandeln dann operiert.
Ja, ja, Sie haben schon gesagt, ja.
Und nach war das ganze Zeit gut.
Aber jetzt vor fünf Jahren hatte ich wieder eine Erinnung.
Aber die wurde gut behandelt und ich musste mich schonen.
Und seitdem ist das in Ordnung.
Okay, okay.
Ich verstehe, ja.
Und haben Sie etwas bemerkt, zum Beispiel Scheiden aus Filos oder etwas?
Haben Sie das bemerkt?
Ja, alles noch.
Und schlafen Sie gut, Frau Holzkanz?
Normalerweise schlafe ich gut.
Die letzten drei Nächte habe ich nicht gut getroffen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Sie haben auch schon gesagt, leiten Sie an,
zur Seite Zufizidlosigkeit, ja, und Duschfälle.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlisten?
Ich habe jetzt so stark geschwitzt und wahrscheinlich etwas wenig getrunken.
Also ich habe jetzt in den letzten zwei Tagen relativ wenig Wasser gelassen.
Aber ich glaube, ich habe zu wenig getrunken.
Ja, deswegen.
Ich habe keine Schmerzen beim Wasser lassen.
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Haben Sie Stress auf der Arbeit oder im Leben, die Sie belasten?
Schule, in der Schule ist immer Stress.
Ja, ja, ja.
Aber sonst im Leben habe ich keinen Stress.
Also in der Schule ist schon immer viel, ja.
Geschäftigkeit oder was, ja.
Im Leben keine.
Okay.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie nehmen nur Betrugs.
Und ansonsten gibt es keine Medikamente.
Nehmen Sie, ja.
Und rauchen Sie Frau Holzkanz?
Nein, ich rauche mich.
Noch nie geraucht im Leben.
Nein.
Sehr schön.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, mal etwas Wein, aber das ist selten.
Vielleicht ein Glas pro Woche.
Ein Glas Wein pro Woche.
Okay, sehr schön.
Und seit wann trinken Sie so?
Ja, seitdem ich im Studium war, seitdem ich an der Universität war.
Okay, okay.
Okay, sind Sie allergisch gegen Alkohol?
Nein, alles vertragen.
Und bisher die Medikamente, die ich mal nehmen musste, die habe ich alle vertragen.
Okay, sehr schön.
Und auch möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, ich weiß jetzt nicht, was das sein kann.
Ist das wieder die Medikamente oder habe ich das aus Kamotscha mitgebracht?
Ja, vielleicht.
Es ist sehr früh etwas genauer, ich muss sagen.
Aber zurzeit würde ich gerne sagen, Sie leiden an irgendeinem gleichen Platz für Enkredit.
Ja, vielleicht. Es geht um auch Ihre Geise.
Das kann auch sein.
Ja, Sie reden zuerst, würde ich gerne einfach unter der Suche durchspüren.
Ja, danach können wir noch mal besprechen.
Okay.
Vorholkampf.
Gut, das können wir so machen.
Prima.
Ja.
Gut.
Ja, brauchen Sie jetzt etwas Zeit zum...
5 Minuten wäre es besser, ja.
Ich habe keine Frage.
Es wurden, glaube ich, auch viele Fragen gut gestellt.
Ja.
Ich komme sofort wieder, ja?
Okay.
Ist gleich.
Ja.
Hallo, guten Abend.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin eingenommen.
Alexandra Holtham ist eine 38-jährige Patientin.
Sie hat bei uns wegen Möglichkeit und Fieber seit 3000 vorgestellt.
Und sie leidet an auf die Röhre, sieben, acht Mal, hat sie.
Aber sie hat kein Blut bemerkt, nur sehr süßlich war.
Und sie hat auch vor vier oder fünf Wochen eine Reise gemacht in Vietnam, in Cambodia.
Okay.
Ja, sie hat manche Proflaktie geachtet, zum Beispiel Malaya oder Hepatitis A, B in Punkten schon gehabt.
Und die Malaria-Profilaxe hat sie konsequent gemacht?
Sie hat einen, die Nürnchen, aber vor letzten vier oder fünf Tagen hat sie nicht wichtig angenommen, ja.
Malaria Proflaktie, Malaya Medikamal.
Hat die Behandlung unterbrochen?
Ja, genau.
Wegen Dankprobleme oder was?
Ja, ich mache es um Dankprobleme.
Mhm.
Ja, und sie leidet, sie klagt überall Muskeln, Probleme.
Mialgi, vielleicht können wir das.
Also die Patientin klagt über Mialgien und...
Mialgien, ja, genau.
Und Atralgien.
Ja, sie haben das.
Und sagen sie klagt über Mialgien und Polyatralgi, also Gelenk- und Muskelschmerzen.
Und sie leidet an Chitruma.
Ja, Chitruma.
Einmalig oder eine Strumano-Dosa?
Chitruma-Nodo-Dosa.
Sie hat schon gesagt, Knoten.
Wo der festgestellt hat, aber kontrolliert.
Nehmt sie ein Medikament ein?
Ja, natürlich.
Ötrox nimmt sie 75 Mikrogramm täglich.
Ansonsten gibt es keine Medikamente.
Sie regt ja Medikamente oder bei Bedarfs.
Sie hat schon gesagt, dass sie eine Medikamente hat.
Es geht um die Medikamente.
Sie hat ja auch eine Medikamente, die sie regt.
Und vor Erfremdung ist ihre Entzündung bekannt,
die Hulfigener.
Im Kinderalter hat sie auf mehrmals Mandel entzündet.
Anginatonslaris oder anginafonslaris.
Wahrscheinlich als Streptococcus-Infekt.
Ja, genau.
Und die denierendenzündung ist das eventuell eine Pyrlonifritis
oder eine Glomerlonifritis?
Lässt sich das irgendwie schon differenzieren
oder müssen wir da noch schauen?
Ja, Akte oder Akte-Verprofen, ja Akte.
Ja, die haben recht.
An OP oder Anforce-Operationen ist eine Appellation mit Bekannt.
Ja, und ihr Vater leidet an Leukomie
und ihr Mutter leidet an Mamakatino.
Ja, das ist das Akut für das Mamakatino?
Nie, sie war 46 Jahre alt, aber einen OP gehabt und alles noch.
Und eine Operation bei der Patientin?
Sie hat eine Appendectomie gehabt.
Appendectomie.
Hat sie noch eine Operation gehabt?
Ja, eine Tonst-Lektomie als Kind.
Wahrscheinlich aufgrund der zidivierenden...
Angena.
Ja, wir haben nicht.
Und auch ihre Schwester leidet an Asthma-Bronchdiage.
Sie besucht regelmäßig Urlaube-Logen und Frauenarzt.
Ja, die nekologische Anämpfnis ist umaufwählig.
Und die Niere, ist die seit der Operation in der Kindheit,
sind die Nierenentzündungen kontrolliert?
Oder gab es Rezitive oder erneute Nierenentzündungen?
Ja, ihre Nieren werden regelmäßig kontrolliert,
jährlich.
Aber vor fünf Jahren hatte sie auch sehr wichtige Pologne-Nächerchen
oder Glöld-Märchen.
Aber zurzeit gibt es keine Probleme.
Was denken Sie, was ist Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Meine Verdachtstiagnose ist Tipus.
Ja, Tipus kann das sein.
Oder eine Gastroenteritis können wir auch sagen.
Eine Gastroenteritis kann das möglich sein.
Ja, Akutechastroenteritis, meine Verdachtstiagnose.
Kann es auch eine Pylonephritis sein?
Ja, Pylonephritis.
Pibar, geht das.
Aber warum nicht?
Kann es auch eine Malaria sein?
Malaria, ja, Pibar hat sie, aber du schwellst, geht das.
Sie hat eine Betropenanamnese.
Sie war in Elnam und Kambodscha
und musste ihre Malaria-Profilaxe für vier Tage unterbrechen.
Ja, sie hat es nicht.
Es muss auch ein Hinweis sein, dass eventuell sie sich doch eine Malaria-Infektion hat.
Manchmal ist das einzige Symptom einer Malaria,
ich habe es schon selbst erlebt, nur Diarrö.
Diarrö, ja.
Es gibt auch Orkenten, die gar kein auffälliges Fieber haben,
sondern die haben eine Diarrö.
Klar, dann ist in der Vorgeschichte wichtig,
natürlich zu erfragen, ob sie Tropen auf den Teile waren.
Ich glaube, eine Verdachtstiagnose Richtung Malaria
ist bestellt, Richtung Typhus.
Das ist Gastrointestinal, Infektionscheimes.
Wenn es auch einer Pyrolonifrit ist.
Bei der Vorgeschichte der Tropenreise
natürlich leicht vorrangig eine Tropenkrankheit ausschließen.
Ja, ja, nein.
Oder gibt es bei den Kolleginnen und Kollegen Widerspruch?
Ja, mal da ja.
Warum nicht?
Ja, ja.
Gut, wichtig ist mir nur, dass Sie versuchen,
die Differenzialdiagnose,
die Differenzialdiagnostischen Maßnahme zu machen.
Okay.
Also ich finde Sie haben das in der Anamneserhebung
sehr schnell das Fieber eingegrenzt, auch mit der Reise.
Ich habe extra noch gesagt, ich habe die Malaria-Profilaxe
in der Sympathie begreifen müssen.
Gut, die haben Typhus genannt, die haben Malaria genannt.
Bei Schiegeln haben wir ja häufiger Stühle.
Typhus in der, häufiger nicht, aber auch das,
ist ein sehr buntes Bild in der Symptomatik.
Achten Sie ein bisschen darauf, dass Sie die Fachbebrüche
über Lenden schmerzen.
Sie klagt über Muskelschmerzen.
Dann bitte sagen Sie klagt über Myalgin,
über Atralgin.
Ja, der Vorstellung kitzte ja bei dem Oberarzt ganz wichtig,
dass Sie das übersetzen sozusagen in die medizinische Sprache.
Sonst haben Sie das gut gemacht.
Und um das systematisch gemacht, um alles Wichtige abgefragt.
Ob die richtigen Schlüsse am Ende gezogen werden,
ist nicht so entscheidend.
Es ist ja keine medizinische Fachbrüche.
Sondern wichtig ist nur, dass Sie versuchen,
bei so einem Zustand, einem Status Februis
oder vibrilen Temperaturen nach Tropenaufenthalt
zumindest daran zu denken, dass es eine Tropenkrankheit sein kann.
Vielleicht benennen und dann auch sagen,
das werde ich dann durch die Untersuchungen weiter eingrenzen.
Aber natürlich auch noch an die Niere denken,
weil sie eine Vorgeschichte bildet.
Deshalb habe ich extra das mit der Niere noch in der Vorgeschichte
eingebaut, damit es nicht so einfach ist.
Ja, okay.